I never thought it would be seen by a
lot of people but suddenly out of the
blue while I was working in the factory
some person I still don't know who must
have shared it on a blog or you know
listed it somewhere where it got some
traffic because one day I woke up and I
had 20 000 views from that point on I
just started making content because
following that initial influx of traffic
I basically got an influx of subscribers
that I could like okay I'll make it for
these people because you know whatever
and it just kind of snowballed like that
I started thinking about things in terms
of how could I have fun in this job and
also kind of build towards them that I
could potentially do outside it was
still very much a hobby the whole
YouTube thing eventually when the when
the actual contract ended there I could
actually go into another job which which
I ended up working in a place called PC
World I had a much better time there but
while I was working in PC World the
amount of subscribers that I was
bringing in and the amount of money that
I was bringing in through YouTube was
actually in actually ended up paying me
more than what PC World was doing and I
was only doing YouTube half uh part-time
at that point